[Musique]
le 12 juin prochain aura lieu la journée
nationale de lyon ce club mais qu'est ce
que c'est le lieu c'est ce que nous
allons tenter de décorer avec mes
invités christine malet bonjour vous
êtes gouverneur des clubs blind lyons de
l'ouest de l'île de france
c'est dire la yole ce pc lyon s'est
effondré et cécile bophal rougemont
jours bonjour vous êtes membres du yacht
club de montfort l'amaury exact alors on
va essayer d'abord de défi des excuses
d'abord je suis impressionné parce que
je suis devant quelqu'un qui est un
gouverneur une gouverneur alors qu'est
ce que c'est un gouverneur et qu'elles
sont risquées des grades dont le dur ce
club
alors il n'y a pas de grade il n'y a pas
de hiérarchie juste pendant un an les
gnons les mym sens en lion du district
ile de france ouest m'ont fait l'honneur
de m'élire pour donc me confier la
gestion du district est le district
mince et recouvre les trois départements
de l'ouest parisien le 92 le 95 et le 78
et donc recours 81 club est presque 1500
membres lions très engagé donc en
dessous
1509 c'est énorme
on peut peut-être pas les embouts de
l'histoire de ce mouvement on sait
publie c'est là au fond c'est la plus
grande organisation philanthropique du
monde avec près d'un million et demi de
deux membres représentent plus de 220
pays enfin c'est assez énorme
will en quelques chiffres 1 percutant
comme vous l'avez dit pratiquer plus de
1000 1 million 400 mille
lyon dans le monde 46 mille clubs
répartis dans le monde et dans plus de
200 pays
en france c'est quand même 25 mille
membres lions répartis sur plus de 2200
club et on la france est répartie en 15e
région qui s'appelle des districts et je
représente le district de notre région
de l'ouest de tori sciemment ensuite ce
qui est impressionnant aussi c'est de
voir là ce que récolte ce que collecte
les lions indomptables ans les souvenirs
restent un petit peu dans l'histoire
le mouvement né ou à la fin du 19ème
sectionné 7 juin 1917 de société il ya
première création pour la fin du xixème
siècle aux usa et l'afrique rassure la
grèce au lendemain jones passe au
lendemain de la première guerre mondiale
par rapport à tout ce qui s'était passé
qui avait ébranlé le monde
melvin jones est donc un an un groupe
d'amis ont décidé donc de créer un nom
que ce ce premier club avec donc un
objectif humaniste c'est à dire de
ramener la confiance et la paix au
travers d'actions qui répondent à des
besoins et autour d'une devise on ne
peut pas aller très loin dans la vie
tant que si l'on ne commence pas faire
quelque chose pour quelqu'un d'autre et
c'est notre devise c'est ce qui nous
unit tous dans le monde est là il faut
dire que lyon c'est un acronyme
ça veut dire liberté détermination
safety en anglais fait et et puis il ya
la divine we serve nous servons suivie
par 10 avance donc en fait c'est la
liberté et la compréhension sont la
sauvegarde de nos nations et donc avec
pour ciment com.com points comme lignon
de rendre service
nous servons est donc cette devise de
qui est tout à fait officielle depuis
1954 et elle est jugée relevé un peu les
valeurs c'est l'intégrité la loyauté la
toule eros générosité c'est tout à fait
l'euro tous unis au travers donc de ses
valeurs de d'amitié de tolérance de
compréhension
c'est les clubs sont un lieu d'échangé
de débat est un lieu où on fait donc on
élabore des projets et surtout on met
tout en oeuvre pour les réaliser et ces
projets sont des réponses à des besoins
puisque les clubs sont 1 contactée par
soit par les établissements proximité
dont les mairies nous sommes donc des
actions au niveau national et au niveau
international
qu'est ce qu'il fait et je lui ai posé
la question c'est si beau folle route
que vous avez connu celui où ce club et
vous avez eu envie d y entrer
je mangerai là aussi la question est
difficile mais pas vous êtes voilà via
des amis et puis qu'est-ce qui a fait
que j'ai voulu participer à ce
ce grand mouvement en fait c'est parce
que je voulais donner du temps et de
l'énergie pour les autres est leur seul
c'est compliqué en groupe je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus simple j'ai été
accueillie les bras grands ouverts par
les membres du lion's-club donc on a
fondu de la 7 ans notre club de vos
fondamentaux
tout à fait tout à fait et voilà nous
sommes un groupe de 25 personnes
on se retrouve une fois toutes les deux
semaines
alors avant la crise sanitaire c'est un
restaurant après ça a été par visio
maintenant on va pouvoir enfin se
retrouver des nouveaux effectivement
autour d'une table vous avez une
activité professionnelle ou cette mère
de famille vous avez combien d'enfants
j'ai des enfants deux enfants vous
faites de la beauce et je crois oui tout
à fait 1
et vous arrivez à trouver du temps c'est
cette riche chronophage ou pas alors ça
peut être très chronophage mais je pense
que les membres du lions se donne du
temps en fonction d'eux de leurs
possibilités
c'est à dire que là j'ai plus de temps
je vais donner du temps là où j'en ai
moins belle pour en donner moi mais
quelque part chacun fait sa part du
colibri
il y en a qui ont plus de temps est
vraiment à l'image de christine qui est
très très très impliqués qui fait
beaucoup de choses les gouverneurs et
les gouverneurs mais malgré tout elle
elle donne beaucoup de temps aux autres
et puis nous dans notre club
voilà on se réunit en fonction des
capacités de chacun on élabore comme
expliqué christine des projets et on le
sait avec beaucoup de plaisir vraiment
et vos classiques comment vous êtes
rigolions ce club mais en fait moi je
suis médecin il ya donc là long de la
carrière j'avais vu donc toutes ces
belles réalisations
voilà toutes ses actions ses projets
d'envergure qui ont été menées par des
lions et je me suis dit que en deux
note donc en fin de carrière j'allais
rejoindre le lion's-club parce que
j'avais plus ne pouvait plus maîtriser
mon emploi du temps et donc je suis nyon
depuis 15 ans et en fait on croit qu'on
compte donne un petit bout mais on donne
tout son coeur s'était ces magiciens
cadets et là il ya souvent un peu une
image comme ça de deux clubs un peu
bourgeois peu un peu vieillot silva tout
à fait vrai que c'est une fausse image
dont en fait ne bougeait pas il ya de
tout mais je pense que surtout cette
année où on a été ôtée maintenus à
distance du terrain on n'a pas pu se
rencontrer lors de réunions statutaires
ou bien néanmoins les lions on fait
énormément d'actions dans le cadre de la
crise qu vide et de la epide
après donc il ya plein d'action qui ont
été réalisés et qui ont montré une autre
image ah bon donc les vous vous pouvez
aussi venir l'un maintenant m'aider
alors que je suis isolé et que pouvait
m'amener un plateau en plateau un panier
pour un alimentaire pour une pas bien
sûr c'est ça notre notre vrai notre
notre vrai objectif c'est de servir au
plus près des besoins et très sains très
en phase avec les besoins elle cette
année on a été d'aider on a été contacté
en peu de temps on a répondu à un besoin
au plus proche donc des des personnes en
précarité ou isolées ou des étudiants
cette année il nous a donc tous les
instants que ce soit notre district et
en particulier le club allait de
montfort l'amaury mais aussi tous nos
districts et tous les districts en
france on a eu un énorme d'action de
mobilisation pour les étudiants et c'est
une option c'est un fait remarquable
cette année
cécile
concrètement comment ça se passe alors
la bct
concrètement alors là on a réalisé pas
mal d'action pendant la crise sanitaire
avant et pendant bien évidemment on a
fait des petites boîtes cadeaux pour
noël pour les plus démunis mais les
portage des repas au ccrb nice et paul
qui vous appelle c'est vous qui le lie
au club le club et dans la cité donc ça
veut dire que la cité va avoir besoin
ponctuellement dead
alors c'est ce qu'a expliqué christine
via la mairie où il ya différentes
associations
on nous appelle nous demandent de l'aide
et nous répondent présents des membres
exact ça et qui se passe le club a en
fait fallu en ce club et le club en tant
que tel va répondre aux besoins de la
cité aux besoins en régionale aux
besoins en france éventuellement dans le
monde on peut agir vraiment un petit peu
partout après à nous on s'est vraiment
concentré cette année sur les étudiants
en pré carré d'or donc au mois de
décembre on a lancé une grande collecte
on a récupéré des produits alimentaires
et des produits d'hygiène que l'on a
distribué aux étudiants de l'université
de saint quentin en yvelines avec l'aide
du crous par exemple donc les étudiants
qui sont tout seuls dans leur chambre et
pour qui c'était vraiment compliqué
c'était vraiment très très difficile
mais ils ont vu que ils en ont bénéficié
que des gens venez les voir leur
apporter de quoi vivre des produits
n'étaient pas seuls et c'est un moment
d'échangé c'était à c'était bien et de
la même manière le 19 et 20 mai on a
organisé avec visant solidarité la
possibilité en fait aux étudiants
d'avoir accès aux soins visuel à la
santé visuelle corps parce que si vous
savoir c'est que le budget santé pour
les étudiants c'est dur ça ça coûte et
tous les étudiants ne bénéficient pas
d'une mutuelle type man 100% les frères
en charge donc quand on achète des
lunettes et que tout n'est pas remboursé
c'est compliqué et qu'on a un petit
budget donc 19 et 20 mai avec vision
solidarité quatorze étudiants l'ua
et à des soins de la santé visuelle et
des lunettes gratuites le financement ce
moment geek évidence vous aviez un ce
sont celles de chaque club
l'anc se débrouille pour financer
trouver un financement et donc par
rapport à venir sur le covin donc à
partir du mois de novembre quand a
commencé la deuxième vague de cette
épidémie ni au niveau du district on
avait mis en place une plate forme
téléphonique allô solide qu un lot
solidarité lyon et donc c'était c'est
les créneaux des coudes six jours sur
sept étaient tenus par des lions et donc
on avait des demandes qui venait soit
des mérites et ses services des
associations des aides à la personne ou
alors des associations de mandataire
judiciaire par exemple et donc on a
répondu ont relayé la demande aux clubs
de proximité et c'est comme ça qu'on des
clubs ont découvert des situations très
très difficile et au bout d'un moment on
a vu que les demandes s'orienter vers
les étudiants et pour ce qui est notre
district il ya eu donc cette année sept
ses actions faites donc sur versailles
saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi sur
le campus de paris nanterre où en fait
on a aidé donc là il y avait l'épicerie
donc l'agora une épicerie de l'étudiante
qui marchait bien mais on a aidé en
donnant donc des chèques lire des
chèques pour acheter des livres des
livres pour le préparer les exemples et
des plus beaux coups de poing souhaite
juste alors c'est vrai qu'il ya un grand
axe de votre action se développe pour
durable on pas trop le temps de parler
en un mot le 12 juin qu'est ce qui se
passe et est ce que des gens qui sont
intéressés par le lieu peut venir vous
voir
alors oui puisqu'en fait cette année est
exceptionnelle pour plusieurs points
mais en même temps c'est la première
fois qu'ils auront à la journée
nationale des lions de france et donc
c'est le 12 juin
et là ce journal dans tous les districts
dans nos quinze districts tous les
niveaux un maximum de lyon seront sur le
terrain soit pour des actions de
communication soit en réalisant des
actions et
là ils sont disponibles ils auront des
pros sur deux des documents distribués
et donc ils pourront donc répondre à
toutes les questions et faire donc part
de leurs deux de leurs engagements et de
tout ce qui les unit dont l'amitié et la
force du service bravo et merci à toutes
les deux là il ya les brochures un qu'on
peut se procurer ya le site aussi deux
clubs
et puis donc cette journée nationale le
2 juin
merci infiniment de cécile magritte et
sicile beaux fleurons de s'inscrire aux
haut lieux ce club
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]